en cette heure je vis une merveille
pommelé
effleurant les champs
de ces vastes elle céleste
brandissant un bouclier étincelant
où est-ce qu'ils vont alors se qui
s'échappe air qu'on ne revoit jamais
il n'y a rien d'autre que du malheur
dans cette vie
malheurs et des souffrances
il est temps de partir d'ici
mia sur sept navires est recherché pour
le meurtre d'un enfant
cet homme a perdu la trace de ma mère
puis la miette
va pas renoncer si facilement récupérer
la colère toi même te nourrir ainsi sur
mer
c'est ce qu'il ya de pire comme
nourriture
ce qui à terme
sauvagerie dont peut faire preuve
s'il est persuadé de défendre une noble
cause
vous avez fait tout ça avec le chemin de
fer
oui
j'ai abandonné ces gens que j'aimais
[Musique]
n'y a rien
qui est été ouverte
tout a été gagné
accrochez vous
ce
que vous savez construire
vous pensez à qui
[Musique]